[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that'll quiet him down
77-69 he had the crease this strongest
two watches turn the corner on tory and
prince and the edward said i'm gonna
meet you at the apex freddy linger says
no you are not the right market spin
where you can kiss not the best without
using the box
rules on a 16-4 run they force the
turnover
edwards
[Applause]
hit three of his six field goal attempts
slammed down a dunk alive
[Music]
somebody's going to have to come in
jackson off the screen
and john picks off the pass
running with trey bounce to herder love
to collins
[Music]
it's a fun on this one
watch out kelly
watch out
ubra darts inside
numbers for boston brown oh my goodness
he sees miles right there
wow
your net he did
well
the starters are getting a nice little
rest you know you're up 20
with nine to go very comfortable
john collins and alive what a dunk by
john collins reason you have to watch
every night you never know when the
explosion's coming
[Applause]
thing of beauty well you know every time
he does something like that my blood
starts
i think i can go out and try if we can
lower the goal to like eight and a half
feet
nick it's the coming down that's the
problem right they're coming down
there's too much on it you gotta do it
on this side of the floor now
oh wow
robert williams
off the feed from jason tatum jason
tatum knows how to play the game
of basketball
feels mason giving him just too much
attention trying to stop that ball
perfect pass for the young williams
boston bench knows how big this game is
it can't jump over a phone booth of a
phone book but he can play the game
marketing with those long arms with the
steal the nuggets been played by
turnovers
mercy marketing went coast to coast
43 seconds in jokic took that from lowry
martin schroeder beats williams good
challenge by plumley that's what he
brings to this year's club
bridges oh my goodness
dude look at this pass right here left
hand over the head bosses who's that two
it's to zero punch it in